let me show you something i've not seen
in a very long time swedish 80 carry
legend reckless crying in front of an
adoring crowd of fans
at least for myself playing at home is a
really
hard thing to do i love being here in
front of you guys playing with you guys
like it's
[Applause]
but these aren't fans of fnatic or g2 or
any big lec team you won't see them at
worlds this year because they're a
regional french team they literally
cannot qualify so what is this absolute
hall of famer doing with them and why is
this already one of the coolest stories
of the year
[Music]
all right last time i did a league video
i said to you guys hey make sure you
subscribe and that way i know that i can
keep doing them a lot of you did it was
great so let's do it again
round two so let's take it back reckless
was once the face of the european
powerhouse fanatic they went together
well like peanut butter and jam bread
and butter tsm and bjergsen
oh it's still so wrong in 2018 he helped
fnatic all the way to worlds finals the
first time the org or any western team
had reached that far in the seven years
since fnatic lifted the trophy way back
in season one but fnatic weren't able to
build on that momentum they lost their
star mid laner caps to g2 and by the end
of 2020 rekkles had decided can't beat
him join him his move to g2 was a shock
to fnatic fans but made sense from a
neutral perspective g2 had lost perks to
c9 and reckless stepping in to fill that
void made sense on paper with them
perhaps he could finally get his hands
on the world's trophy a third place
finish in spring and a fourth place in
summer resulted in g2 failing to qualify
for worlds for the first time in the
orcs history it definitely wasn't the
fairy tale that everyone expected as
part of a major team shuffle g2 put
rekkles on free agency and set his
buyout at 1.5 million euros there were
some accusations at the time that this
was exceptionally high and the g2's
owner carlos could do more to help
rekkles find a new team but he clapped
back and said 1.5 million was below
market that reckless was free to go
anywhere that was willing to pay and
that they even petitioned riot to let
them loan him out but to no avail so we
were now in a position where a top three
western 80 carry of all time was about
to be teamless less than three years
after he made it to world's finals but
then on november 15 2021 something kind
of insane happened it was announced that
reckless will be joining carmen corb now
if you don't recognize the name you're
probably not french
i'm french
french
i'm french you see the peak of european
league is the lec which contains teams
like g2 and fnatic but europe also has
the erl the european regional league
which contains the french league that
k-corp competes in the lfl the teams
here are smaller they have smaller
stakes smaller signings smaller budgets
but one thing that rivals the lec
perhaps even surpasses it at times are
their fan bases especially k-corps these
guys are fanatics for their team literal
die-hards honestly the closest thing
that i've seen is football fans back
home in england and if you want to see
what i mean just take a look at when
reckless was first presented to the fans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy i absolutely love it there's more
passion there than in like 10 years of
the lcs and i say that as a big lcs fan
sorry lcs this time last year k-corp
weren't even known outside of france at
all that all changed in may 2021 though
when they won eu masters the tournament
which pits the best european regional
league teams against each other this
really put them on the map they became a
pipeline for european talent current lec
players such as adam x mattie and targer
mass have all featured in k-corps lineup
in recent years and they've also managed
to retain talent too legendary top laner
cabo shard had the chance to rejoin the
lec while playing for k-corp but he
chose not to he chose to stick with them
that's how strong their momentum is
right now make no mistake this isn't a
vacation for rekkles or an early
retirement his dedication to be the best
hasn't waned at all this is the way i
don't think taking a break was the way
to win worlds i think this
might be you know i have a chance here
to actually
think about everything i'm doing start
over a little bit
bring all the good stuff remove all the
bad stuff maybe add some stuff and
next time i come back to lsc i'll be
more of a
complete person player all that stuff
and then hopefully i can win worlds that
is the goal reckless offers them a solid
veteran foundation and a brand to add to
their own they offer him a route to get
back to the lec and play at the highest
level without any drama or big team
politics and perhaps most of all kcop
has offered rekkles something that the
past few years of underwhelming results
may have taken away
real
passion at no point was this more clear
than in k-corps game in the lfl last
week when rekkles got his first ever pen
to kill for the team you don't have to
understand french to understand what's
going on here and why the fans will keep
screaming louder every week
yes
[Applause]
if reckless goes on to win worlds now
whether or not it's with this team
i think it would be
one of the craziest esports stories ever
like
ever i mean
he was in the lec
things didn't work out there he joins a
regional team he works his way back up
to the top and then wins worlds
you don't get better stories than that
it's insane i'm already excited and
there's still only a small chance is
going to happen